willkommen zu unserer zweiten gesetzten
Rede und zwar von unserer
Außenministerin Annalena baerbock
jaburg war die federführenden Ministerin
zu mindest innerhalb dieses Grünen
regierungs-teams für diesen
eu-kompromiss nach der Entscheidung hat
sie auch einen Brief an die
Bundestagsfraktion geschrieben auch noch
mal betont wie schwer das gefallen ist
persönlich
wir spüren ja nicht nur in diesem Raum
sondern wir haben es alle in den ganzen
letzten Wochen gespürt wie sehr uns
diese Thema dieser Kompromiss zerreißt
peter hat das vorher noch mal deutlich
gemacht als Anwalt in der
Flüchtlingshilfe andere die selber
geflohen sind oder Verwandte haben die
geflohen sind aber auch viele von uns
ganz normale in der Partei Abgeordnete
Landesvorsitzenden und deswegen danke
ich für diese Debatte heute und auch in
den Vortagen auch wenn sie schmerzt uns
alle schmerzt aber sie ist nötig genau
wie ihre gesagt hat sie ist nötig weil
wir eben als Partei einiges anders
machen
ziemlich egal was Zeitung darüber
schreiben und auch mich hat es zerrissen
natürlich wie kann das anders sein als
wenn letzte Woche
ausgerechnet wo die Frage war scheitert
das sowieso generell weil niemand
überhaupt einen Textvorschlag hat
ähnlich wie bei unseren
änderungsveranstaltungen manchmal
wenn dann noch ein Bild reinkommt von
einem Schiff das gerade untergeht wo man
denkt das kann doch jetzt nicht sein
und zeitgleich bekanntermaßen war ich da
gerade in Lateinamerika ich in diesen
Tagen zwischen Dienstag Mittwoch
Donnerstag dann SMS bekommen von meinem
lieben Freund und Außenminister Kollegen
aus Luxemburg zum Beispiel der
Außenminister und Integrationsminister
ist der sagt Anna wir sind weiter
vollkommen alleine bei den Kindern wir
kriegen gar nichts
aber wenn wir jetzt gehen dann verlieren
wir auch all das was wir in einer
möglichen Verteilung haben
und ich hatte eben nicht nur die SMS und
die Nachrichten und die Anrufe als
Außenministerin ich hatte immer meine
eigene Stimme im Ohr gerade an diesem
Mittwoch Donnerstagnacht morgen
als ich als Parteivorsitzende kandidiert
habe
und selber gesagt hat stellen Sie sich
vor es wäre ihr Kind damals ging es um
den Familiennachzug
und ich habe gedacht das kann ich meiner
Partei nicht zumuten das kann ich uns
eigentlich nicht zumuten ich kann es mir
nicht zumuten
aber das ist mein Job mein Job ist mir
genau das zuzumuten wenn wir so
schwierige politische Entscheidungen
treffen bereit zu sein sich vorzustellen
was würde das für ein selbst für die
eigenen Kinder bedeuten und dann aber
einen keine Einzelfälle zu sehen sondern
auch andere Menschen andere Familien in
ihrer Situation und auch wenn diese
Redezeit waren sich knapp ist würde ich
versuchen euch einen kleinen Einblick zu
geben also habe ich mir vorgestellt was
es bedeutet wenn wir in diese
grenzverfahren gehen wo vollkommen klar
war wir kriegen diese Familien dort
nicht raus weil nur Luxemburg am Ende
noch ein bisschen Irland und Portugal
auf unserer Seite waren
da war für mich vollkommen klar das geht
nicht diese Verordnung geht eigentlich
gar nicht für uns als grüne ich habe das
auch deutlich gesagt ich habe gesagt das
ist falsch
und zugleich habe ich aber all die
anderen Verordnung gesehen ich habe den
Ordner mitgebracht 800 Seiten es ging
eben überhaupt um andere Verordnung
und da habe ich mich gezwungen mir
vorzustellen und was bedeutet das jetzt
für die anderen die anderswo betroffen
sind zum Beispiel das Kind was ich in
Athen getroffen habe im Flüchtlingslager
letztes Jahr war schon ein paar Jahre in
Griechenland ist immer noch nicht ihren
finalen Bescheid bekommen hat wo mich
die ganzen flüchtlingshelfer da gefragt
haben Frau Berber wann kommt das jetzt
endlich mit ihrem verteilmechanismus sie
haben doch gesagt freiwillig das haben
wir versucht in den letzten anderthalb
Jahren maltermechanismus zehn Länder von
denen sind zwei übergeblieben
Deutschland und Frankreich 3000 Leute
verteilen wir darüber 1700 nach
Deutschland Frankreich ich weiß es nicht
so ganz genau also habe ich mir
vorgestellt was bedeutet das jetzt wenn
ich wegen der ersten Abwägung zu allen
anderen Verordnungen auch Nein sage das
dann das was wir erreicht haben was
nicht unser grüner Vorschlag auch nicht
der Vorschlag der Bundesregierung war
dann auch nicht Thema nämlich gar keine
Verteilung mehr ja diese Verteilung
verpf lichtet nicht jedes Land Ungarn
gar nicht dass die Menschen aufnehmen
aber sie macht deutlich dass wir von den
3000 jetzt auf 30.000 gehen und das war
für mich der Punkt wo ich sage wir haben
im Vergleich zum Status Quo eine kleine
Verbesserung und wir haben erreichen
können
[Applaus]
und wer kam erreichen können und ich die
Uhr tickert hier runter und bitte wenn
jemand ein paar Minuten gibt wir haben
erreichen können das ist mir wirklich
wahnsinnig wichtig weil es am Ende eine
ganz ganz schwierige Abwägung war
den Punkt dass in der
asylverfahrensverordnung Artikel 41
steht meines er will die tankt es geht
darum die grenzverfahren Erika und ich
haben rauf und runter wie interpretiert
man jetzt Shell
das ist in der Regel eben nicht so ist
das
familiengrenzverfahren in Haftanstalten
kommen da steckt da auch mit drin das
sind alles Details aber all diese
Details sind eben mit reingekommen weil
wir mit verhandelt haben und dann ist
noch ein dritter Punkt für mich
entscheidend gewesen
abzuwägen weil ich eben nicht nur als
grüne Außenministerin verhandelt habe
sondern auch als Europaministerin und
auch als grüne Europaministerin und weil
wir dieses Dilemma in unserem
Grundsatzprogramm genau beschrieben
hatten das ist Momente gibt wo ein Ziel
von uns gegen ein anderes Clash dass wir
das Dilemma haben wenn wir mit
Mehrheitsentscheidung in Europa
abstimmen das Deutschland überstimmt
werden kann
und auch das ist was wo aus meiner Sicht
wenn ich mir vorstelle wenn es um unsere
Kinder geht wenn es um zukünftige
Generationen geht mit zu berücksichtigen
ist wir leben gerade alle das die
Freiheit und der Frieden in Europa nicht
vom Himmel gefallen sind sondern das ist
unser wichtigstes und kostbares Gut ist
und deswegen war für mich auch so
wichtig mit zu berücksichtigen was
passiert wenn die Länder und zwar nicht
Ungarn und Polen sondern die Länder die
das Verbindungselement rausstreichen
wollten Italien zum Beispiel ernst
machen wenn es gar keine Einigung gibt
dann habt Ihr uns auch gar nichts mehr
zu sagen erst recht nicht vor dem EuGH
weil dann machen wir alleine was wir
wollen auch das gehört die jedenfalls
für mich mit dazu und dann am Ende
dann Ende muss man
am Ende muss man abwägen abwägen was
wiegt jetzt hier mehr oder weniger und
auch da danke ich für diese Debatte und
sie war glaube ich für uns alle ein
bisschen schmerzhaft weil er geht es
nicht mehr um dieser Fakt des richtig
und dieser Fakt ist falsch sondern was
wiegt bei so einer Entscheidung höher
die Frage dass wir das bei den
grenzverfahren nicht erreichen konnten
oder die Hoffnung dass nicht
3.30.000 und es ist so angelegt dass es
120.000 werden die nie Verteilung gehen
was ist für uns wichtiger und wie sehen
wir die Gefahr dass Europa wieder
nationalstaatliche Antworten erst recht
bei Flucht und Migration verfällt ich
glaube niemand hier im Saal kann sagen
hundertprozentig ist die Waage so
meine Waage und die habt ihr dann alle
gehört und ich weiß dass sie für manche
überraschen kam meine Waage war 49 zu 51
und deswegen finde ich auch richtig dass
wir hier in diesem Antrag nicht sagen
kann das war die allerbeste Entscheidung
dass man das dann so mitgetragen hat
weil ich verstehe total dass die Wagen
von anderen anders waren erst recht wenn
man nicht als Außenministerin darauf
kommt erst recht wenn man vielleicht
nicht als grüne darauf schaut sondern
als eine Anwältin für Menschenrechte und
geflüchtete daher möchte ich nicht dafür
werden dass wir sagen das war alles
super ganz im Gegenteil ich möchte dass
wir deutlich machen gerade weil wir es
unterschiedlich bewerten kämpfen wir
gemeinsam umso härter ich möchte dafür
werden
dass wir uns
dass wir uns weiter etwas zumuten ich
möchte dafür werben dass wir eine Partei
der Zumutung bleiben egal wie sehr sie
schreiben wir sind zerrissen und diese
Zumutung kostet Mut aber warum bin ich
davon überzeugt dass uns etwas zuzumuten
besser ist als alles andere weil wenn
wir uns dieser Zerrissenheit nicht
gestellt hätten nicht weiter jetzt im
Trilog stellen
dann füllen diese Lücken andere und die
brauchen keinen Mut die brauchen auch
keine Zumutung aber die sind doch Martin
wir sind submatisch wenn wir uns als
Bündnis 90 die Grünen nicht dieser
Zumutung stellen dann werden andere
Entscheidungen fällen dann hätten die
Feinde Europas und Menschenrechte Feinde
der Menschenrechte gewonnen und ich
glaube diese Partei wurde auch vor 40
Jahren gegründet nicht dass wir uns auf
die Schulter klopfen nicht dass ein
Parteitag eine Außenministerin zujubelt
sondern diese Partei wurde auch vor 40
und dann vor 30 Jahren vereint damit wir
dafür sorgen egal wie hart der Gegenwind
ist egal wie hart die Zumutung wir
werden weiter für ein freies Europa wir
stehen weiter ein für die Menschenrechte
danke schön
die Außenministerin Anna-Lena baerbock
ich hatte noch mal Einblicke gegeben hat
in den schwierigen Verhandlungsprozess
innerhalb der indem sie ja dann zum Teil
auch eingebunden war und sie hat das
beschrieben sie hat ja hadern
beschrieben und hier so Umarmung auch
mit Eric Marquardt den Film
Europaabgeordneten der ja zu einer
völlig anderen Bewertung bekommen ist
und der sagt mit diesen
Verhandlungsergebnissen wird keine
Verbesserung erreicht werden der Ball
wird aber auch bei den Grünen
Europaabgeordneten
den dieser trilog-prozess der wird sich
ja im Europäischen Parlament zwischen
Europäischen Parlament EU Kommission und
den Staaten dann vor allem abspielen
aber hier gibt es Rückenwind und
Rückhalt der Partei auch für die grüne
Außenministerin